hey guys it's just stayed and I'm super
excited because I'm not really sure what
is inside if here this is an extremely
unexpected surprise I got an email from
D brand the other day and they said hey
we'd love to send you some of our new
Nintendo switch skins at checkout and I
said yeah I love switch accessories I
love my Nintendo switch I love
everything about it so yeah of course I
would love to check out the skin
no I opened up the package I was like
wait a minute this is an entire console
what's happening so thank you guys so
much I'm so excited to open this up so
this is gonna be a complete shock I
don't know what's in here at all I did
check out some of the things online I
will also put a link in the description
if you guys want to check this out they
have so many different custom
combinations so I don't even know what's
in here but let's open it up together
and see what's in here because I have no
idea I mean I doesn't intend to switch
I'm assuming unless there's not an
intended switch in here so one of my
favorite colors is purple and if you see
right here we have got the purple jewel
icons and so it's great about dbrand is
they are just skins
so essentially this is a sticker that
you guys can put on yourself I'm sure
you've heard of them so I know what
something they're saying you probably
had heard before there was a huge
problem with the previous version of the
debrie a Nintendo switched skins the
adhesive was damaging them Tendo
switches so there was a bunch of
articles there was reddit threads there
was everything so I did ask about that
because I was super curious and
definitely was worried that if I did
show this to you guys and it did damage
or switch you'd be mad at me but they
worked with 3m to resolve that issue and
made an entirely new formula so if this
has been tested and they said that it
will not damaged or switched and hold on
a second
this is oh man
guys this is a white Nintendo switch you
may remember back in the day I had
all-white consoles and I was really
excited about it until the Xbox one X
came out and then that one was matte
black and then the PlayStation 4 Pro
came out and then that one was black no
freaking way this I did not expect the
whole front is white the inside of it is
purple to match the joy cons this is all
this is just this is a piece of work
this is art I need to see what this
looks like all together these guys oh oh
my goodness I'm gonna be causing a scene
when I'm cruising through the airport or
well not really cruising it which is
basically sitting in a corner playing my
video game well this one has a little
white sticker and a pink sticker same
assuming that these are white and pink
joy cons but I don't want to assume
anything because this is completely
unexpected
so only two favorite actually make three
favorite colors or here or wipes not
even a color purple and pink or am I to
Bureau my favorite colors it's like it
actually almost matches my nails except
the nail sole and they kind of messed
them up this time but whatever well
let's take a look what's in this one
this is just something out of a dream
well thank you deep bran so much because
this is such an unexpected surprise and
uh wow I've been such a huge fan of you
guys forever so thank you this is
amazing let's see what the white looks
like on here this is just
is a sight so beautiful I can't believe
it
let's try the pink on might as well have
all of my favorite colors a whole lot of
mine switch at the same time can you
believe it because I can't definitely
think this is probably one of my
favorite looks it looks so fresh like
can you just imagine me sitting on a
plane like this is gonna be me
probably in three days when I get on a
plane wow I'm I just keep saying wow and
I'm so excited but like I don't know
what else to say I don't any other words
to describe my feelings and since I'm
here a lot of you guys had a bunch of
comments and said that this is going to
brick your switch but this isn't a dock
so it won't break your switch it is
essentially just a charger I saw a bunch
of comments if you guys say my next
video was gonna be the switch charger
bricked my switch but it didn't it
hasn't I've been using it for quite a
while actually and it's not a dock it is
a battery charger so you should not have
any braking issues let me know if you
guys have a favorite color combination
if you guys check out the website let me
know what your favorite is and you could
make a dream colored switch what would
it be I would love to know in the
comments below so feel free to leave
those and bonus points if you photoshop
in your favorite dream color switch and
tweet them to me you guys are new here
be sure to hit subscribe and even if you
are new and if you're not new make sure
you guys hit the bell because that's
basically the only way that you'll be
able to get my videos and know when I
post new ones so either way welcome to
the family and welcome back to you guys
who have been here since the start I'll
see you later
freaking out
[Applause]
[Music]